thank you
[Music]
it's time now for CBS deals this morning
we're sharing a few items that just
might help make your day a bit easier
and a bit more fun all at exclusive
discounts to start shopping now scan the
QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass
joins us with more good morning good
morning and what do we have here we have
stuff to make you look beautiful and
make you feel beautiful and have a good
time I love this this is you got Bye
Felicia now you got by acne this is from
solar wave go to CBS deals we're right
at cbsdeals.com right now because this
is for people who want to do those spot
acne treatments what's really cool about
this is you turn it on I'm going to show
it right there you turn that on over
just like that it has red light and blue
light and right there you put it up
against where you want to do a spot acne
treatment we don't have acne sometimes
you do sometimes you have to admit that
yeah I get acne and you and you set it
and you just hold it on that spot you
want to and it works and it turns off
after three minutes there you see how
easy it is to use you just put it on the
spot you wanna you you want to treat
what I like about it is when you use
spot acne creams and those gels it makes
my skin peel and I get that hyper
pigmentation post acne this helps treat
that and helps prevent that that's what
it's designed to do all right and I love
the price on this you know what you go
for a facial to get all that stuff costs
you over a hundred dollars we have this
for 69.99 that's 30 off less than a
treatment for facial and I presume this
is I don't know this is portable you
could put it this fits look if it's in
my pocket nobody has to know I'm gonna
make my skin yeah good and color
coordination oh yeah option his and hers
there you go are they yeah they yes yes
so what is this this looks fun this is
fun this is the tiki Tunes now what's
great about Tiki Tunes is not only does
it it's a Bluetooth speaker but it is a
tiki torch that doesn't have any flame
so you could take this outside because
look the weather's been beautiful here
in New York for the weekend right if you
were having a picnic today and it goes
into the night you have a little
lighting this is a great hostess gift as
well I love that there's no open Flames
oh perfect danger element is not yes and
you saw how light that was you could put
you could pair two of them together to
have like stereo surround sound so if
you're having that party or need a
Hostess gift boom Tiki Tunes is it for
you it's all about the three yes it is
how much we have them for buy one get
one free so it's 49.99 for the pair oh
nice yes oh I love oh Poo probiotics
because I have started using probiotics
what's great about these is I'm going to
show you how easy it is to take these
because these you don't need water you
just open them up like this all right
and then you just pour them on your
tongue remember that old candy used to
pour in your tongue how about that that
old medication used to pour on your time
and I have the mint flavor you have the
chocolate and mocha which is like wow
and see how quickly it dissolves this is
for people who want to improve their gut
health wow if they're doing if they're
doing something with weight management
this is the thing this is what it's
designed for hard to talk though
something in my mouth on TV I'm trying
to be elegant about it but this what's
great is that I like using this because
I don't have pills and all that stuff I
have to carry around and what's really
good is the last time I had a gummy it
was a kid's gummy let's let's be let's
be real here I had a kids coming and I
had 300 worth of dental work because the
gummy pulled out one of my implants so
there you go we have this for 31-12 it's
under 32 dollars for a month supply
this this is perfect for me in the
summer because let's face it I am like a
chocolate fountain with kids in the
summer because mosquitoes love me they
treat me like a 7.99 buffet in Las Vegas
you get into the mesh pod
and just like that you have protection
from mosquitoes and you also have shade
these have magnets to hold the door
closed so you could sit in your chair
read belonging by Michelle
or or Tony decopal's book you could sit
in a chair or put the babies in here to
keep them protected from Bugs how about
rain there is this is designed to keep
give you shade and in the sunshine
because this is going to have 360
airflow so you're going to get a little
water in here this is for Sunshine you
could take it to the beach look at this
you could take it to the beach you could
take it to the park you see how easy it
is to fold up you can see how
lightweight it is I'm holding it up with
one hand
leave it in the car for the summer 29.99
yeah we have that deal thank you of
course we partner with all of these
companies get to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head on over to CBS
deals
.com